parce que c'est quelqu'un qui est
extrêmement polémique extrêmement clivé
savoir que true cité claudel sont
arrivés avec leur petit bouquin aussi
avoir une dédicace de monsieur renaud
nous apprenait par coeur même les
articles de renom donc c'est flaubert se
mettait à genoux devant renault dans le
sang le mouchard amis je vous en supplie
écrivez moi quelque chose pendant
saint-antoine qu'avez vous pensé de
salambo qu'avait lancé ma bobonne l'an
passé il est considéré comme le
successeur de victor hugo
je suis doctorante en littérature
française
ce concert est le dix neuvième siècle je
travaille sur un auteur qu'on a un peu
oublié aujourd'hui qui était vraiment
important en dix neuvième siècle
s'appelle un astronome alors il est
important puisque par exemple la notion
de vivre ensemble et on parle pas mal
aujourd'hui bien lui la vie de jésus sa
télé best seller absolu du dix neuvième
siècle quand le livre est sorti
cent cinquante mille exemplaires dans
l'année puisque les misérables
mais les prêtres se déguiser pour aller
l'acheter parce qu'en fait le pape a mis
le mur à l'index
donc tout le monde est dans toutes les
messes disait il faut surtout surtout
surtout pas lire la vie de jésus
donc les gens comme cette île il allait
acheter la jazz au lieu de l'acheter et
ça ça va être un gros tournant sur la
sécularisation en france c'est à dire le
début de la laïcité avant la loi de 1905
est d'accord on a commencé à faire des
études bibliques qui ne soit pas faite
par des prêtres tu vas nous faire un
très bel exercice de vulgarisation c'est
pour ça qu'on est là ce soir
justement on est donc à une soirée au
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
une soirée qui s'appelle savoir les
démocraties qu'elles sont mots clés qui
ont été données pour animer des
conférences des ateliers et des
discussions moi j'ai quelques questions
ont été posées du plaisir qui sont en
lien avec ma la raison pour laquelle on
va inviter savoir la vulgarisation sur
youtube
donc je voulais savoir si tu regardes et
youtube sur les gars des vidéos sur
youtube
d'accord je regarde mondialisateurs ces
derniers temps alors pour le coup comme
je savais que nous allions rencontrer
j'ai dévoré tâche est donc je te regarde
ta différence elle fume mais vu que tu
es dans les dernières vidéos que j'ai
regardé en sur youtube
alors je fais à usage habituel des
gendarmes beaucoup m'ont dit des choses
comme ça plutôt que d'aller sur deezer
ouais bof ça me paraît assez simple
et qu'est ce que tu penses de cette
plateforme est ce que tu en es plutôt
satisfaites plutôt critique qui je pense
qu'il ya plein de choses intéressantes
qui a plein de choses potentiellement
intéressante mais
que kylie a peut-être soit un manque
d'ambition sur un manque de moyens mais
j'ai l'impression que les vulgarisateurs
qui mettait pas mal à la mode sont plus
fatigués maintenant ou qui plus est plus
fin qui sont fatigués en fait c'est
qu'il ya quelque chose qui est qu'il y
ait un peu répétitif on est habitué à
des pharmas de deux chaînes seront une
bonne - maintenant c'est pour ça que je
te pose la question est-ce que tu
acceptes de la légalisation parce qu'il
ya des gens qui veulent à la réfute
totalement parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
envisager le quelque chose de touchant
ciel non je préfère que savoir vivre
même trompiez vraiment mais après dans
un monde idéal tout le monde pensera
exactement comme moi et en une poule c
est la contradiction les erreurs les
interprétations ça s'est vraiment bien
je devrais dommage qu'on me prenne que
mes travaux que des travaux de gens
travaillent si renan c'est parce que
nous sommes des légers mais renan et
calvin qu'il dépasse la vulgarisation et
qui ne supporte pas l'idée d'une science
populaire et c'est pas idiot parce que
non mais parce que pour lui l'absence de
toutes façons c'est exigeant et dans la
maison c'est exigeant il n'est pas
contre le fait que les gens fassent de
la science il est contre le fait qu'on
vend de la surface il est donc le
populaire divertissante et la médiation
c'est nous à comprendre aux gens que
c'est compliqué normand fait ce que je
voudrais vraiment sur youtube maintenant
les verts c'est parce qu'on va débattre
tout à l'heure j'ai réfléchis en ce
moment j'aimerais pas alors la seule
voie pour interdire qui que ce soit mais
j'avoue que ça ici éducation les
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
en bois jeux des vidéastes qualifier un
bien castés donc des zones et des femme
intelligente cultivée alors avec une
petite équipe comme sacrés de la vidéo
la belle vidéo et qu'ils aillent
interrogées disent merci très bien
structuré ça ce serait vraiment très
triste pour s'achever sur youtube on me
suis dit soit je fais une thèse tout
seul dans ma chambre
on a cinq disques de chevet parce que
j'ai pas de finances qui montrait des
ados je fais la même chose dans ma
chambre mais là je me mets sur internet
à la lecture de tous mais très
clairement je n'encourage pas quelqu'un
à se lancer dans une thèse si on n'en
est pas sûr
sans financement je n'ai pas mes 100
prochains profession faire une thèse
sans vouloir être chercheurs
d'enseignants s'est pas loupé
c'est trop tôt un peu été trop d'huile
on n'en fait rien sur marché du travail
si vous avez en q3 de la recherche il
n'avait pas forcément besoin d'être un
peu de ça je me dis vraiment à tout le
monde c'est vrai le val le but c'est à
dire les modéliser sénat parce que en
tout ce formatage sera monuc en format
essai
vous allez rencontrer des scientifiques
de leur écrire tous les chercheurs sont
accessibles parce que leurs adresses
mails sont en ligne on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir une carte de doctorants par des
chefs ça c'est vraiment important c'est
ça sera enregistrée ou c'est juste pour
toi ah oui oui c enregistrés sur quoi
donc je présente nicolas métier physique
je suis chercheur en sciences politiques
je veux des recherches sur l'évaluation
des politiques publiques et comment on
analyse les politiques publiques et on
essaie de rendre des comptes aux
citoyens
anthony ali je ne suis pas chercheurs
mais je travaille au cnrs et je m'occupe
notamment des relations
institutionnelles du cnrs et des
relations entre science et société au
cnrs et donc toutes les actions du cnrs
vis-à-vis de la société
alors moi je suis ici parce que j'ai
lancée en fait l'idée de cette nuit
qui avait pour objectif d'ouvrir une
pouvoir un ministère faire rentrer les
gens dans un milieu qui leur paraît un
peu lointain et venir dans ce lieu pour
entendre parler de savoir deux choses
qui est qui et concerts on parle de
démocratie notamment et avec l'idée que
recréer du débat revient entre
l'institution et
exactement et questionner aussi les
grands enjeux les grands défis qui nous
concerne mais je pense que c'est plutôt
réussi à ce que ce soit on a bien il ya
du monde partout où il ya beaucoup de
jeunes mais on semble pas trop envie de
débattre de de dialoguer et cette envie
de politique en fait qui est pas
forcément localisés dans des parties
mais qui est une espèce de débordements
ça fonctionne très bien parce que moi
avant de venir
j'étais stressé plus tard je suis vert
vingtaine d'institutions monde ça
et c'est une forme de violence un peu et
institutions justement n'est pas on
n'est pas chercheur
les archives en place et en fait c'est
très facile ça se passe très bien
en fait il ya l'espace de violentes
gelabale anthony mais il ya un espèce de
violence un pastiche enel c'est à dire
que les gens ont l'impression que ils
n'ont pas le voir accéder et c'est vrai
pour les savoirs aussi comme pour les
lieux de les lieux de pouvoir on a
toujours l'impression que c'est quelque
chose qu'on a un peu dévié ou vérifier
que
c'est loin de nous alors que finalement
ce sont des institutions qui vous serre
qui sont en service de deux tours et la
politique c'est là la gestion commune
des affaires de la cité
et c'est ça qu'on voulait faire aussi
avec cette nuit équipes généralement
ce moment c'est de faire quand on crée
des événements s'est reconnecté la
science
et la société ce qui m'a vraiment
intéressé c'est à la fois rendre
accessible justement du débat
scientifique ou du débat sur des
questions scientifiques diverses et
variées aux citoyens à la fois en tant
que participants mais entend aussi que
simple auditeur est le lieu qui n'est
pas un dieu donc c'est un peu ce que tu
disais mais c'est vraiment pas un loup
qui est ouvert au public c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un dieu qui est
inaccessible pour beaucoup de gens ce
que tu dises également que tu étais un
peu stressé avant d'arriver c'est vrai
que peu de gens savent à quoi ça
ressemble un ministère peu de gens
savent comment ça fonctionne et la
l'ouverture de ce lieu rendre l'espace
au citoyen et à toutes les personnes qui
veulent participer au débat public
je trouve ça vraiment intéressant et
c'est ce qui m'intéressait mais comment
est ce que ce soit fait de manière si
regardez vous et youtube moi oui aussi
ouais maintenant qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de cette plateforme en fait je
suis pas un bon qu'on se met en fête de
youtube donc je sais pas forcément
d'avis éclairés sur le sujet j'y vais
surtout pour regarder pour écouter de la
musique rend compte c'est plutôt la
consommation j'en fais que j'en fais pas
une consommation je ne suis pas bonne et
à des chaînes je regarde pas des
contenus des savoirs j'ai une
utilisation très montrés très limités
très concentré sur un secteur qui est
plutôt la musique
moi je suis arrivé sur youtube par la
musique justement pour aller voir les
clips ray pour profiter un peu de toutes
les nouveautés musicales mais je
m'investisse de plus en plus à la fois
sur le côté information puisqu'il ya de
plus en plus justement de reportages où
on peut trouver de plus en plus un
reportage vidéo mais également sur le
côté découverte par certaines chaînes
youtube de gens qui
justement explique un sujet soit à
partir d'une vidéo ou d'une situation
vécue et qui vont expliquer donner un
point de vue et j'ai l'impression que ça
se développe beaucoup ça se développe
énormément en tout cas moins il ya
quelque chose qui est sûre c'est que
c'est ce vers quoi je tant en termes
d'utilisation est ce que tu es amené
parfois à vulgariser t on cherche auprès
d'un public différent les chercheurs
dont je pense que ça c'est essentiel si
c'est faire de la recherche pour parler
seulement à communauté scientifique et
le pain ne pas aller au delà et
présenter un public plus plus profane
experts
les enjeux le syli sujet test en fait je
trouve que la place du chercheur c'est
d'aller au delà
donc c'est d'aller présenter dans des
arènes qui ne sont pas forcément qui ne
sont pas forcément acclimaté au sujet
est qui et qui ont envie d'entendre
parler de sujets de manière simple j'ai
fait par exemple le matin en deux
minutes c'est quelque chose qui avait
lancé c'est le monde et le film donne
poste pour aller présenter la recherche
sur comment les citoyens rencontrent
rendre des comptes
après j'essaye de faire des conférences
aussi qu'ils sont las pas forcément des
conférences des arènes spécifique mais
qui sont dans d'autres lieux je crois
que c'est je crois que c'est essentiel
parce que ce que font les chercheurs et
les travaux des chercheurs
donc c'est un tour sur ce que il ya ce
côté un peu intello et qui
ki moon ira est en fait entre la
recherche et le grand public qui est
plutôt qui plutôt désastreux parce que
dans l'inconscient collectif est une
espèce d'epinal du chercheur et je pense
que c'est ce genre de choses qu'il faut
casser ses représentations
c'est ça ces représentations chercheurs
c'est des gens qui sont sur le terrain
qui collecte de l'information quand ils
font des sciences humaines et sociales
qui sont des sociologues et comprendre
qu'ils essayent de comprendre les
mécanismes comment la société fonctionne
quand ils sont dans des laboratoires ils
essaient aussi de faire des avancées
scientifiques qui permettent de
lutter contre certaines maladies c'est
ça en fait qu'il faut montrer s'ils font
un travail fondamental pour pour le
reste pour la société c'est pas un truc
mais ils sont juste là en train de se
retourner se parlent entre eux et c'est
pour ça que l'initiative de vulgariser
et d'ailleurs c'est peut-être le terme
vulgarisation les chercheurs n'aime pas
parce que je trouve ça un peu qui
demande une dégradation de leurs de
l'autre avant de leur travail peut-être
le côté davantage dire ne rend plus plus
pédagogique accessible six ans c'était
peut-être le terme en fait qui dérange
aussi un peu certains chercheurs et mais
je crois que ça c'est hier je vais le
faire bien sûr que jamais on fabriquait
qui fonctionne et vulgarisation et c est
ce que tu imaginerait que l'on travaille
sur youtube j'attends mettrait donc si
vous me donnez l'occasion d'expliquer en
fait
je pourrais prendre mais je pense que ce
serait une ça serait bien ce serait bien
parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que
les médias sociaux et les canaux les
canaux les canaux vidéo notamment et le
poids de l'image une explication c'est
c'est ce qu'il fonctionne cécile
fonctionner et quand même lire une thèse
j'ai fait une thèse en sciences
politiques les montes de 500 pages en
sciences politiques il faut déjà être
très motivé à aller acheter la thèse
dans une librairie puisque la thèse a
été publié chez un éditeur
c'est aussi une étape youtube les vidéos
sont virales on peut parler de manière
un peu plus
moins technique et laisser tout
l'intérêt il ya une production de
connaissances erreurs et mettre cette
production de connaissances sous
différentes facettes et ça c'est un vrai
ça c'est un travail essentiel pour
réussir à faire d'une manière j'ai
beaucoup merci elle a fait un sketch
elle incarne la l'avocate de deux
manuels fillon et laporte dit alors je
travaille plus spécifiquement sur
comment en fait on peut comment les jeux
vidéo influence modifié suicide des
changements de comportement chez le
joueur ouais j'ai aussi un deuxième
postulat 4 est important c'est que
l'expérience de jeu est d'abord quelque
chose qui appartient l'être humain ne
s'est pas l'objet qu'il définit c'est un
jury c'est l'expérience que toi tu as
avec l'objet qui qui est vraiment l'un
des jeux que je te vois j'observais
c'est pas ce pack bleu la seule
définition c'est pas un truc le plus
vrai du monde mais c'est ce qui
m'intéresse moi dans
me choque donc je suppose que tu
regardes des regards des chroniques sur
youtube
je dois beaucoup son regard beaucoup de
moins en moins malheureusement parce que
j'ai de moins en moins de temps mais je
regarde beaucoup de chronique tant aimé
cette idée celle d'être déchaînée qui tu
inventes de cerveau c'est la chaîne de
damas tess et la chaîne 2 de pierre
josse pas comme neuf je veux vraiment
pas comment ça se prononce
créer c'est trop génial les deux chaînes
damas tc pierre toujours les mêmes
crimes
mais ce sont des tout petit chai qui
méritent vraiment d'accord donc regarder
je vais beaucoup et j'en garde beaucoup
de personnes jouer parce que en fait
c'est gêner beaucoup regarder les gens
jouer à des jeux vidéo j'aime regarder
donc forcément beaucoup de personnes qui
qui se filment en train de jouer qui
parcourent des jeux entiers comme ça
inutile personnel comme moi oui ma
bouche je ne filme pas en train de jouer
par contre j'ai c'est de faire un bon
niveau un petit peu de vulgarisation de
guns east 10 en fait
en fait tout simplement je prends des
textes scientifiques des textes de
recherches sur les jeux vidéo ce qui
honnêtement je j'essaie de sélectionner
des textes qui le servent déjà dans mes
recherches
le test
comment à s'attacher esteban grimm
estevan gagne du coup qu'est ce que tu
penses de cette plateforme youtube ce
que tu en es satisfait est ce que tu
critiques à être ou pas si ça vient pas
personnellement aux vrais gens n'est pas
tant que ça
je pense que mes critiques rejoignent
les critiques générales qui s'en fait à
la plate forme après elle m'a permis de
faire des choses est de faire connaître
mon travail et donc ça bah voila je peux
pas trop je peux pas trop lui retirer sa
il ya une question qui revient souvent
dans le milieu
tu es notamment de la vulgarisation
c'est la question est légitime
oui toi tu en penses quoi et c'est c'est
difficile je pense que
n'importe qui peut être légitime avec
une bonne méthodologie clairement après
je pense aussi que c'est important de de
faire preuve d'honnêteté intellectuelle
et de ne pas essayer de se substituer
aux sources de me laisser de se
substituer toi de ne pas faire passer
son travail comme plus important que ce
qu'il a vraiment été j'estime que quand
on la légitimité est né à elle existe à
partir du moment où on essaie de mettre
en place une méthodologie qu'on peut
présenter et que on peut être critique
et scientifiquement sur cette
méthodologie là mais la médiatisation a
une légitimité
je pense que c'est aussi de faire
entendre aux gens qu'on éloigne pas
savoir notamment
mais après c'est ultra pour moi c'est
ultra important de deux tu vas même
quand on ne le sait pas donc pas essayer
démentir la cemac cesser d'accepter déjà
qu' on ne peut pas être omnipotent et
omniscient et que c'est pas grave si on
ne sait pas et puis après toujours
de faire preuve d'humilité dans son
propos et puis aussi dans les réponses
que l'on fait parfois en commentaire
celles ci ont dit on n'est pas légitime
bon bah là tu tu fais de l'élitisme
justement lui qui décide
à quel niveau c'est légitime et là il ya
toujours plus fort que toi pour ça donc
je vois à partir du moment où il ya une
méthodologie qui peut être présentés
équipe est critiqué c'est bon c'est
simplement
mais attention
[Musique]
et sans complexité